bonjour à tous en direct ce midi encore
des jeux équestres mondiaux à caen
bienvenue dans votre édition régionales
du 12/13 en normandie depuis le studio
france télévisions installées sur le
site et par expositions de caen flanc un
bon jour ce vendredi ma première semaine
de compétition on tire à sa fin et la
première médaille française
enfin hier en dur à saillé première
médaille pour cette équipe de france
d'équitation dans ces jeux équestres
mondiaux on va le voir une médaille
d'argent une médaille par équipe
décrochée hier soir par les français en
endurance et c'est une surprise
contrairement à de nombreux concurrents
les français ont su gérer parfaitement
ce marathon de 160 kilomètres on n'a pas
vraiment d'image de joie car l'épreuve
s'est terminée très tard hier soir
podium lui n'aura lieu que cet après
midi né à roanne c'est une très belle
médaille cette équipe de france
d'endurance en individuel victoire de
l'un des favoris le prince héritier de
dubaï dans le cadre majestueux du mont
saint michel onfray ont égalé hier tout
au long de cette journée avec des images
magnifiques pour ce véritable marathon
équestre et comme décor on l'a hissé
paysages sublimes autour du mont saint
michel et après plus de onze heures de
course est un concurrent des émirats
arabes unis on va le voir qui va
franchir seul en tête la ligne d'arrivée
a sorti dans la manche
son nom a man al maktoum c'est tout
simplement le prince étiez de dubaï le
fils de l'émir de dubaï l'un des hommes
les plus riches du monde
médaille d'or est arrivé princière donc
pour rahman al maktoum que vous voyez
ici accueilli partout de sa cour
il faut dire qu'à dubaï l'épreuve
d'endurance c'est un évènement
considérable
l émir de dubaï avait mis de très gros
moyens pour préparer et tentez de gagner
ce titre
regardez ça vaut bien un petit bisou
pour le prince héritier qui remercie son
cheval le moyen-orient qui est également
au centre d'une polémique aussi
concernant un cavalier de bahreïn au
public pour de cet homme là que vous
voyez hier pendant la course sur son
cheval nasser bin ahmad khalaf a c'est
le fils du roi de bahreïn plusieurs
associations de défense des droits de
l'homme l'accusent d'avoir ordonné ou de
sept livres
lui même à des actes de torture sur des
opposants au régime en place à bahreïn
en 2011 amnesty international notamment
a demandé à ce que la justice française
profite de sa présence en normandie pour
l'arrêter et le juger puisqu'il serait
ici à titre privé et donc privé de son
immunité diplomatique
merci florent l'une des autres épreuves
phares de ces jeux de londres ce sera
demain le proche du concours complet un
parcours d'obstacles de 6 km 500 à
parcourir en 35 km heure de moyenne et
membre de l'équipe de france ont pu
revenir le tracé hier
reportage arnaud matteoli et mathieu ni
belkovski invasion bleus dans les vertes
collines de normandie
l'équipe de france du concours complet
au grand complet c'est le cas de le dire
aso peigne fin les 6 km ce instant du
parcours du haras du pin décryptage sous
tous les angles voir les pieds dans lors
des quarante cinq obstacles sont des
calculer la distance exacte au
millimètre près c'est à dire hors pair
pour nous c'est hier qu'a si on respecte
nos minutes on doit ré dans le temps
idéal l'a emporté en parlant de ton mais
celui du ciel cette fois la météo
normande plus qu'incertaine boury les
inquiétudes des cavaliers tricolores
si le temps se tient comme ça on devrait
quand même avoir un terrain à un bon
terrain ça va pas être allé vraiment
très bien drainés cette piste-là et pour
l'instant ça ne laisse courir
aujourd'hui effectivement sereinement un
terrain lourd et là ça se complique
encore plus le le cross est un obstacle
au quai qui s'avère finalement pas signé
on tape que ça et bien d'autres qui
seront à première vue m'a finalement
abordé avant de s'attaquer aux obstacles
du parcours
un défilé pas comme les autres les mains
glandus au couple cheval cavalier passe
au scanner visuelle des vétérinaires
tout le clan français passent avec
succès l'obstacle médicale le concours
complet qui se poursuit florent dorin
marie que toujours l'épreuve de dressage
et le conflit on l'a dit c'est un peu le
triathlon de l'équitation et en
attendant le cross donc et le saut
d'obstacles la semaine prochaine les
cavaliers débute aujourd'hui par le
dress
au haras du pin du pain vous voyez ici à
l'image de français maxime livio qui
étaient en lice matin en attendant cet
après-midi le passage de jean soler le
porte drapeau de cette équipe de france
l'une des très sérieuses chances de
médailles pour les tricolores
ces jeux équestres mondiaux si florence
midi on s'arrête sur l'un des deux
sports en démonstration dans ces jeux
équestres mondiaux le très spectaculaire
horse ball une discipline que l'on
compare parfois un basket à cheval
présentation avec vous florent turpin
ce matin là c'est à l'aube et sur la
plage il nous avait donné rendez vous
pour une séance improvisée
bienvenue dans la manche
c'est ici que s'entraîne à longueur
d'année l'un des meilleurs plus de 11
ans terry celui d'agon coutainville un
club qui affiche fièrement sa couleur le
rose au monde du cheval
un look aussi c'est au début des années
70 que le horse ball fait son apparition
en france
le principe est simple deux équipes de
quatre cavaliers ou cavalières
s'opposent sur un terrain d'environ 70
mètres de long pour marquer les joueurs
doivent lancer sous petit ballon dans
des bus fixé à 3 mètres oscille entre
dessus du sol lors bol c'est un mélange
de plusieurs sports mais on a aussi donc
la page football rugby et là pas de
pression comme ça donc on peut dire oui
l'horrible c'est comme la seule
discipline équestre collective alors on
parlera du polo mais paulo s'est pas
tout à fait pareil parce que les joueurs
il tranche d'équipage pour moi nous
toute l'année on est avec les mêmes
coéquipiers ou les mêmes coéquipières
avec le même coach et c'est à saint lô
que les horse ball heures d'agon
coutainville dispute plupart de leurs
rencontres à domicile chaque année le
club d'accueil notamment une manche de
coupe d'europe
hans paul les matchs ne dure que deux
fois dix minutes un franc pour les
chevaux capron et cavaliers un sport
hyper spectaculaire aussi pour le grand
public et régla sont hyper street et on
a enfin à la pêche on va on sait qu'on à
partir d un bord de n'importe quoi et
puis cela sont sinon la sanction à
l'énorme atteint lots en bons celle du
web leur voler pour la première fois ce
pauvre de démonstration qui quatre jours
de compétition et plus de 2500
spectateurs attendus à chaque match
l'ambiance bouillante dur bol c'est la
force de ce sport ce pourrait être la
grande surprise de ces jeunes étaient
aux mondiaux pour le monde de horse ball
en tout cas c'est un événement un
événement alors non je veux que ce soit
notre tremplin
ce qu'on veut c'est que notre discipline
après ça ça explose sport de
démonstration cet été en normandie
le horse ball déjà tous de faire partie
des disciplines officielles dans quatre
ans lors des jeux équestres mondiaux
2018 au canada
raphaël dubois bonjour vous êtes
l'entraîneur sélectionneur des équipes
de france de horse ball
aujourd'hui le horse ball ce n'est plus
un loisir c'est un vrai un vrai sport
exactement c'est effectivement un vrai
sport qui demande plusieurs qualités
d'une part être un homme de cheval m
capable de monter et dresser évolué à
cheval à vive allure et la deuxième le
deuxième critère si effectivement d'être
assez doué avec la manipulation navale
un sport originaire d'argentine mais qui
a été codifié en france
oui le ses origines du horse ball
viennent du poteau argentat et il a été
effectivement que dit
pied par deux français il ya environ une
trentaine d'années dans le bordelais ce
qui saute aux yeux c'est l'ambiance
incroyable qu'il ya autour des matches
ça chante ça danse c1 comme une ambiance
de stade de basket de salle de basket de
salles d'aude vous casser tous les codes
uns par rapport aux autres disciplines
de petites nations qui sont parfois un
peu guindée exactement cette érection
sport collectif
on joue là en l'occurrence on jouait à
saint lô donc à guichets fermés ce qui
représente environ 2500 3000 personnes
et on n'est plus pétillant une ambiance
de stade ou les le public peut
participer à tout moment et n'ont pas ou
en début ou en fin d'épreuve qu'on peut
le retrouver en dressage cso ils peuvent
participer pendant pendant les 25
minutes que dure en main vous êtes sport
de démonstration pour ces jeux équestres
mondiaux est ce qu'il ya une chance un
jour de vous voir sport officiel de jeux
équestres ben c'est notre déjà
effectivement je pense que la discipline
à bout d'arguments pour intégrer dont
collège dit autrement si un sport qui
est abordable dans la qualité des
chevaux c'est à dire que n'importe quel
pays à la possibilit et de monter une
équipe de hand ball
donc par rapport aux disques des
olympiques qui demande quand même
d'ailleurs des vaches d'avoir des des
chevaux à prix assez élevé non à la
qualité pouvoir de pouvoir enfin tout le
pays pourrait proposer des équipes avec
leurs chevaux de 2 de leur pays cette
semaine ce que l'on peut voir à saint lô
c'est un tournoi amical entre quatre
équipes nationales exactement il ya 80
ans pour un tournoi de démonstration
donc qu'il y a l'italie l'espagne la
belgique et la france
c'est effectivement un tournoi de
démonstration maintenant on nous sommes
favoris depuis longtemps maintenant la
france et c'est vrai que toutes les
nations que l'on rencontre encore seul
souhait c'est de nous battre donc
effectivement on est sur 20 tourner
démonstration mais qui reste quand même
assez assez engagé à voir à saint lô
merci à vous raphaël dubois d'être venu
nous parler horse ball de midi dans le
12/13 direction à présent le village des
jeux où le soleil a repris ses droits
aujourd'hui après plusieurs jours de
pluie conséquence la fréquentation papa
était toujours au rendez vous et les
commerçants font grise mine voyait ce
reportage d'alexandra hutin et de jean
michel qui
la gratuité du village à partir de 11h
du matin
va-t-elle enfin décidé le grand public à
venir au parc expo beaucoup de
commerçants dans le village s'inquiète
des promotions fleurissent des prix sont
réajustés les comptes ne sont pas bons
l'opération est même en train de se
transformer pour eux et une partie de
leurs employés enfin j'ai licencié 25
collaborateurs soit sans moi c'est dur
pour les collaborateurs c'était dur pour
pour nous en tant que patron en tant
qu'humain et économiquement
effectivement dans cette mécanique d'une
réduction de coûts ont préféré dans une
mécanique de d'absorption de chiffre
d'affaires supplémentaire les 300 m² de
cet espace restauration sont loués 45000
euros les deux semaines sans compter
pour le restaurateur les charges les
places de parking 22 personnes étaient
embauchées ici pour le service et la
cuisine
huit ont été licenciés là aussi parce
que maintenant on n'est pas dans le
calcul est à combien vos objectifs
on est un important moyen par jour on a
quand même s'ils restaient mission
mondiale et c'est pas le cas je lui pour
comparer avec d'autres événements quatre
fois plus de visiteurs ont fréquenté le
village du vendée globe
cette année il est vrai que côté météo
la normandie n'a pas été gâté en début
de semaine les conditions météo nous ont
pas favorisés effectivement sur une
fréquentation optimale donc les choses
autant tu as évolué on est sur une
fréquentation qui va qui étiez
grandissante qui est progressive on
dépasse quotidiennement les dix mille
visites avec le beau temps qui fait
revenir on est très confiants pour que
cette fréquentation est encore présent
et pour que sais je reste un succès pour
tous
la fréquentation du village doit donc
tripler dans les jours qui viennent est
passé de dix à trente mille visiteurs
par jour et toujours en direct dans le
12 13 depuis le village des jeux
équestres mondiaux on va rester dans les
allées où nous attend et les nz wright
helen bonjour après un drôle de zèbre il
est aujourd'hui vous nous parlez cheval
miniature
bonjour erwan bonjour à tous et oui j'ai
réussi à trouver une des races de
chevaux les plus petit au monde
falabella et j'ai avec moi chez rick qui
est fantaisiste et castres
eric bonjour bonjour c'est quoi ces mini
chevaux heureusement pas traiter de
poneys parce qu'autrement c'est des
petits chevaux des chevaux miniatures et
si vous les traitez bonnaïs vexe 6 70 à
80 centimètres au garrot suprême est
plus ou moins viennent d'argentine le
corps mort ce bol on en parle et
viennent gentil nos départs oui alors le
berceau de la race et en argentine je
les appelais i woke up l'est berceau de
la race et en argentine
mais eux sont nés en europe alors
comment passez vous qui êtes artiste de
cirque depuis 30 ans vous étiez à
combattre et acrobates et s3 vous êtes
passé des grands choix au mini chevaux
ah oui c'est passé l'âge venant je tombe
de - roux est alors dites moi c'est pas
longtemps à l'est de rester c'est la non
non non aux heures par jour inna pendant
pendant quelques jours quelques semaines
quelques mois des dix ans en dix ans que
je travaille avec eux à lui quand même
dix ans alors on va pierre et qu'on peut
vous retrouvez tous les jours ici dans
démonstrations spectacles 3 faut un jour
et je voudrais monsieur ça vaut le coup
merci hélène retour sur ce plateau du
doubs se résout nous a rejoint l'équipe
de france de réunion et de reno grand
complet merci des trains nous guide
huchon guy duponchel pardon vous êtes
l'entraîneur de cette équipe on vous a
déjà aussi un peu plus tôt cette semaine
mais là vous êtes un petit peu changé
vous avez une moustache en moins
explique new skies c'est parce que
bonjour bonjour à tous oui effectivement
c'est un pari j'avais hier matin dans
les écuries spa a démarré avec les
grooms en fait les cavaliers n'était pas
au courant
j'avais dit au groupe si jamais on a
interdit qui rentre sur les trois qui
étaient dans l'épreuve de repêchage qui
rendront la finale je rase la moustache
et il y avait des actrices couvreur qui
étaient là qui est la gomme de romuald
il me dit t'es sérieux tu rates j'ai en
plus eu si romuald here un tyran que je
fais et lm commence à me dire alors tu
racheter la moitié après tu fais l'autre
moitié non non justement
romuald foire c'est vous qui avez eu le
scalp la moustache de guy duponchel en
vous qualifiant pour la finale samedi
soir cette finale driving au parc
d'exposition immédiatement exactement
mais deux caps ne pas garder chez les
côtés c'est oui oui sincèrement et
l'idée c'est de
de faire un score très correct pour
pouvoir entrer donc été à le faire
c'était c'est bien c'est une expo miss
ça a joué à quoi je crois et sport qu'il
fallait faire et 216 me donc en étaient
deux affaires le sport et deux ex-aequo
donc je crois qu'on a fini à 6 oui
c'était ce qu'il fallait faire guy
duponchel ça conclut bien une semaine où
le ring était en force sur ce que josé
castro mondiaux oui c'est vrai qu'ils
ont je pense qu'on est bien représenter
notre discipline
on est un petit peu là pour ça
évidemment le deuxième objectif c'était
d'être parmi vous on parle de nous que
la france cette discipline est cette
équitation et j'espère que ça va durer
période bouygues pour le prévenir il
fait on a essayé de mettre le feu mais
surtout le public qui on remercie
énormément le public était vraiment avec
n'utilise à encourager croyez-moi quand
il rentrait dans la carrière pouvait
demander à romuald à mon avis le frisson
qui traversait pas ce que vous en pensez
quoi de son public romuald exactement à
ça c'est impressionnant
c'est impressionnant ça sent fort et ça
après moi j'ai essayé de mettre un petit
peu à part pour essayer de préserver mon
parcours mais j'en ai profité à la fin
très fort donc c'était super ça vaut le
public américain a carrément oui
carrément
non on était maintenant il y avait de
l'ambiance non l'ambiance lui détient
m'a dit on encore un peu de travail il
met au point de vue du public ils sont
pas apparemment plus on n'a plus qu'a
perdu faut bien merci vous tout ce que
je peux vous empruntez votre chapeau
pour votre coup de deux le cndd sonne
pas ce que je ferais bien florent turpin
avec voilà hop on va mettre du repas
vous avez parié quoi vous à 20h samedi
la finale et roanne samedi à 20 heures
arnaud matteoli bonjour les jeux
équestres mondiaux c'est aussi cet après
midi sur france 3 avec au programme
christian choupin vive nelson monfort et
pierre subi you qui vous commenteront le
dressage du concours complet le dressage
musique et le podium de la médaille
d'argent d'endurance donc tout ça c'est
sur france 3 15 heures d'été vous
retrouverez le résumé complet de
l'épreuve d'endurance dans tout le sport
ce soir sur france on vous retrouvera
également tout le week end dans stade 2
bien sûr dimanche pour suivre en détail
dans les coulisses victoires en 7
victoires 7 médailles d'argent
d'ambiance
qui avoue arnaud ma théorie les jeux
équestres mondiaux sont également à
retrouver sur le site internet de france
3 basse-normandie à l'adresse bastille
rennes amendis point france 3 points et
faire avec vous le voyez notamment ce
matin un article sur 250 jeunes
cavaliers qui sont en train de rallier
en connaît pays la loi
le site du haras du pin ils assisteront
à l'issue de leur randonnée équestre à
une épreuve des jeux voilà un an florent
il faut rendre le stenson acquis du pro
frêche il avait mis à l'envers
il ya encore des progrès avant que la
france soit sensibilisé aurait
visiblement sa candidature merci à vous
tous c'est d'avoir participé 13 merci à
toute l'équipe de france et division
sport qui nous permet d'être présent
tous les midis et tous les soirs depuis
ce village des jeux équestres mondiaux
la formation régionale revient ce spa
avec pour les téléspectateurs de basse
normandie un nouveau journal en direct
de ces jeux équestres mondiaux et en
haute normandie un 19 ans présenté par
frédéric nicolas demain dès midi pour
toulouse où ken vous retrouverez laurent
marvyle en direct toujours le sait josé
qu'est ce qu'un seul film âge dans un
instant le 12/13 se poursuit avec la
votre édition nationale
bonne journée à tous et bon week end